you know i've got my best dad ever
signed right here right okay it's a it's
a
uh a huge honor uh to have this here
every day
certainly six months running now i'm
best dad ever no competition
well i mean there might be competition
but so i'm going to have
put place in front of it justin for our
next guest
this was a a bobble head we got in our
days with at t
when we used to be part of the same
family uh the nba on tnt bobble head set
there we go
good sounds rich and uh and uh charles
and our next guest
i place that right there on the desk for
uh my next guest
uh fellow native new yorker uh one of
the best analysts in the business of one
of the best shows
uh on television two-time nba champion
and the man who's going to be talking
also about his
jet academy kenny the jet smith how are
you kenny
hey man what's up how are you doing i'm
doing fine i got your bobble head right
here
i got it you know you've probably seen
this all for you guys in your bobble
head right at your desk collector's item
man right there i
i i have them but my kids have broken
them up so like
yeah someone it looks you know it looks
like
in my house the bobble heads look like
it's a roman
thing where the nose is the arm is
missing sure yeah
it's like a roman thing i'm going to be
honest with you i can say this thing
sort of thing that uh they they
definitely put more hair on ernie
um and and charles and shaq are
slimmed down this is not this is not
real you're this is as close
you're as close to real as they have and
this bobblehead said kenny
hey man that's my motto we keep it real
here
yeah i kinda absolutely we're again
we're from the same city i totally get
it i understand no doubt
all right kenny what's going on with
hardin what do you know what can you
tell me what do you think's going on
with him
from outside looking in just like
everyone else um
i i i've met james you know on occasion
you know i don't know him well you know
and um
but just outside looking in he's a guy
who was like looking at his career
if i was him this is what i'd be
thinking am i gonna win a championship
like seriously am i gonna be if i'm
gonna win a championship being here in
houston
are they putting the right pieces around
me you know we changed
i was really comfortable with the
d'antoni system he put the ball in my
hand
you know and they were making moves like
you know we bring in westbrook like it
don't work but you know
they're making but moves i going to win
a championship here with this new regime
that would be my question and i think
that's his question
i don't know if he wants to be out of
houston but i know he wants to be out of
a situation that doesn't want to be
if i was him that's not going to win a
championship
i only got about three or four more
years of this like where i could carry a
team
like where i'm carrying a team pretty
much basically by myself
that you know where i can get you to the
semi-finals
of the west after that i'm not able to
do it
so if i'm james harden that's what i'm
saying
right now and if you're james harden
what do you think kenny i mean you know
the houston organization well
um do you think that's i don't know this
one well okay
but i would say you'd have to sit me
down and convince me
that what we're doing or going to do
is going to have me an opportunity to be
in the western conference finals the
next three years
because the way i'm looking at it the
clippers and the lakers
are uh ahead of we would we were ahead
of them
for two years when chris paul was here
even though you know didn't work out
but we were there and we're not there
anymore
so i guess this would also um not lend
much credence to whatever
reporting that's out there that harden
was working out with john wall
and kind of gave a green light to
houston to swap wall for uh
westbrook if he's thinking that this
isn't the right
mix do you think it could be the right
mix
i think you know a healthy john wall
you know but we haven't seen i haven't
seen john wall play basketball in two
years like literally i haven't seen him
he's a great player when two years ago
he was
you know top five point guard in
basketball
you know i haven't seen him play
basketball in two years so i have no
idea
you know we you can work out with a guy
all you want but until you see him play
in a real nba game i could bring you
five guys right now that's not the nba
rich and we said hey let's go work out
you'd be like why is this guy not in the
league
like well you haven't seen him play you
see him work out
it's a big difference right and then the
word is that harden was also working out
with durant and kyrie here and
and thought maybe this would be good to
do professionally word that he might
i think he always works out you know he
works out at a gym
you know i know about i just got in
chris brickley who's a big trainer
in new york they work out that gym all
the time that's not unusual
there's a guy in la now he works with um
uh with sacramento he runs the gym out
here
uh you know those guys work out those
gyms all the time and they play with
each other that's not unusual
if you're in the basketball community
james harden and kevin durant and kyrie
were in the same gym at the same time
it's not unusual um if you know the
circuit
no sure and it's not unusual anymore for
guys to be working out and saying you
know what this is fun
let's do it professionally and then
like all of those guys work out together
like even when i was playing there's
like five gyms around the country that
everybody used to go to
like when you're in that town you're
gonna be like up let me get a run in
you know let me let me get a run in but
so it's not unusual
um so i wouldn't read into the whole
he's working out with kyrie
and and i wouldn't read into that
honestly but i would read into the fact
that
this guy might not feel he can win a
championship any long longer in houston
and if you look at their roster you go
they're not better than five teams right
now
are they better than denver right now
not necessarily you know
that we're going are they better than
portland not necessarily
are they better than the lakers no are
they better than
clippers no like you know that so
i can understand the concern well
kenny the jet smith here uh on the rich
eisen show and then the ultimate
question
right now um outside of los angeles here
obviously would be
uh the question involving giannis and
and the bucks
getting jeru holiday and trying for
bogdanovic not landing him and this
appears to be
their message to him as he has this
decision uh
by december 21st to accept the supermax
or not what do you think is happening
there in milwaukee
best you can think on this um
i think giannis is in the same vote as
james like
but but he still has years to do it uh
you know he i think because he's younger
uh
and he's more you know at the upsync
upswing of his career going
you know i have an opportunity to you
know to really create a legacy that most
players don't
so and it's a different era where guys
have to be convinced that you're all
doing that uh
where i think 10 15 years ago
you would say you don't have to convince
a guy a guy would say
i'm going to be here because i'm pretty
sure this is going to be the same
ownership group i'm pretty sure it's
going to be saying coaches
i'm pretty sure this is gonna be same
management change general magic
things flip so fast in the nba now
and you know that it is
the same management group it isn't the
same team
that does it it's the same ownership
team
primarily and and it is the same coaches
in the same thing you look at there was
nine new coaches last year in the nba
it isn't the same so the environment
changed and changes
and doesn't allow players to have that
freedom of thought
what would you do if you were him i was
y'all i'll be like
i i if i was jonas i would sit down
i would play this year and i wouldn't
worry about it until the end of the year
i would i wouldn't i wouldn't think
about it i was like we're going to see
how this year goes
and um because milwaukee also you know
they change
a lot of their management in terms of
you know
uh general managers and presidents over
the last couple of years four years
let's see who's going to be here let me
see if i really
engage in that before i make a
a huge decision well it's not like like
i'm going to be anything different at
the end of the year
right so if you're the bucks wouldn't
you take that as an indication of uh we
got to get him out of here we better get
something for him
i mean wouldn't that set off a whole
bunch of alarm bells that would be like
for me if i was the bucks i'd be like
hey
this is gonna this is who's going to be
here making the decisions for you
trust these people and those people
would be
i would be at every game every practice
every workout that giannis does to
let him know that we're here this is the
group that's going to be making the
decision and we're going to be happy
with you
you're going to be happy with this group
and you're going to have certain input
that you won't you might not have the
final input but you will have input
like at the end of the day we still have
to kind of say
yeah that's a good move but we're gonna
like
put you in some of these kind of
conversation kenny the jet smith here on
the rich eisen show the jet academy of
an online basketball camp for children
of all ages we'll talk about that
uh in one second just put a pin in that
one last item to hit you on
talking about uh the honest decision and
talking about what hardin's thinking
is this all just rearranging deck chairs
with anthony davis re-signing with the
lakers and lebron
getting his extension and schroeder
joining the team they're getting younger
if not
better and now zach lowe reporting pal
gasol might think about
joining this group as well with dwight
howard howard having left uh
what what do you think kenny no it's not
rearranging live furniture because the
the long furniture
anthony davis is part of this discussion
like two years ago you know what i mean
so like if he doesn't make that move to
the lakers or they don't make that move
and get
that trade going then all of a sudden
lebron james is in the middle of the
pack of the western conflict
so this isn't lawn chair moving this is
billion dollar business or multi-billion
dollar business well i guess
i know i guess i mean for the rest of
the league that it just did
you know doesn't matter what the rest of
the league is doing this is the lakers
world and there's no catching them
based on these decisions no no no you
could catch them
because you know there's players just as
good like giannis can like honestly not
looking at
the lakers and going we can't assemble a
team close to that
or or james harden's not saying oh i
don't think i'm
just as good as anthony davis or lebron
i don't think those guys are thinking
they're thinking like i'm just as good
as one of them so
all i need is somebody close to him you
know what i mean tonight and then we got
the pieces around me and i can get those
guys
but right now i don't know if i have
next to me
all of that like and i don't know if we
have a commitment
to keep doing that so
it's not long to this is like these are
real decisions that can change the
landscape of basketball if you make the
right one
and there are certain franchises who
historically don't make the right
decision
you know and they get close and then
they don't not
understand the mindset of a champion and
how to create that they have a skill set
they put a guys with a bunch of skill
but they don't have a mind they don't
understand how to lead into the mindset
and they don't
bring in the right players they don't
make the right draft picks
you know miami's not in the finals by
accident like
those aren't the best 10 guys that you
can imagine jimmy butler
with you know a guy who's been on three
teams and three in three years
you know like these aren't the guys that
everyone says these are the guys you
know what i mean
you know tyler hero from kentucky and
you know
none kendrick nunn and like who brought
the guys
they're in the finals there's a reason
there's a mindset
that is brought about that you have to
have as well
and pat riley and those guys down in
miami is supposed to they have it
and i guess if clay was healthy you
could talk about the warriors just
within their own division their own
conference
i'm wondering exactly you know they have
the mindset you know
you know the warriors have the mindset
that the management staff
you know have you know
everything that you're talking about you
know they don't make
decisions when you talk about bob myers
like he doesn't make decisions
that you don't go man you can win at all
making that decision
you know i mean like you're at the top
you're back at the top of the heap
making that decision you know that's
every every franchise doesn't have that
you know messiah
you jerry he makes decisions that you go
the layman can see internally as
basketball people
even yourself rich being in the mix you
go man that was a deep decision how he
made it
but the layman could see it like people
who don't follow the game every day and
go man
they might get it they might win it all
let's talk about the jet academy sir um
there's a special deal available through
the holidays
um at jetacademy.com i'll give you the
floor to remind everybody what this is
and what uh what
what they can get right now especially
yes i'm excited holiday season's here
everybody so get a pen
get your phone out tap it in the
jetacademy.com what we're giving away
right now is when you sign up uh for the
one year which is 29.99 a month
29 less than a dollar a day you get
a free t-shirt free basketball and jbl
headsets
but what that gets you is really it's a
streaming service and you work out
daily and weekly with your favorite
players
you know we just have a new launch with
draymond green
tj mccollum kobe white kendrick nunn as
i mentioned earlier
uh you know cole anthony like all of
these got nicely a little
like all of these guys are now part of
the jet academy and you get to work out
and stream live with these guys work
side by side it works on any device
anywhere all you need is wi-fi or cell
service and you can log in
and you get all of those things for
29.99 a month
again the jet academy dot com write it
down
put it under the christmas tree and now
your kids get to
get work on that game because zoom
school is going to be out you're going
to be like what am i doing during the
holidays with my kids mm-hmm get in my
bed
oh no doubt for an hour and there it is
you got an
hour on me and i i actually do classes
as well
and you know you work on shooting you
know i'm not moving as fast as
you know uh emanuel quickly you know
who's signed up one of the rookies
or or like i said or or draymond green
or or or cj mccullum but
i'm showing you how to get your shot
right yeah and then you can also
uh run back sessions available for
playback on demand so
if you can't hit that uh that one hour
um you can do it whenever you want and
previously you could go play back
exactly you can go back and see kemba
walker trey young
you know all those guys you know brianna
stewart brittany griner all of those
people are on the playbacks
already done session yeah without
question
ah he's a good dude i hope he's going to
come back as strong as ever here so uh
yeah yeah he said he's healthy man i
talked to him the other day he said man
so bessie's felt he's like i'm almost
there ken i'm like
he said i think i'll be there in like
three weeks i'm like oh that's perfect
timing that's good
fantastic and my kids know noah's work
from the mass singer as much as the uh
indiana pacers
that's a fact hey kenny uh loved uh
talking to you
uh best to you and your family around
the holiday season tip-offs right around
the corner man i'm looking forward to
all that and so let's uh let's
let's talk um as regular as you're up
for it
i'd love it all right man thanks for
having me right back at you that's uh
kenny smith
uh at the jet on tnt on twitter at
thejetacademy.com
is how you can get involved and i cannot
tell you how
uh if you can steal an hour or two from
just taking your kid and saying go and
check this
out and get out there and actually move
around as well
that is uh that is huge that would be
what we call huge
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here